hey let's go brush ma'am
oh my god [ __ ] that was loud Jesus
welcome to brand new let's play and I
know what you're thinking I'm still
gonna play outlast but this game came
out today and I've been excited for it
for a very long time so I'm gonna play
dude I'm gonna play today I know you
guys would love it - it's called lil
nightmares he may have seen me play this
already a little bit before it's a
really quirky different looking type of
horror game it was [ __ ] scary - well
at least what I saw
so far I'm super pumped for this I'm so
lucky so many games are coming out
lately it makes me so excited
I don't really it's weird like sometimes
there's no games sometimes we're blessed
with a [ __ ] ton of games and it seems
like that's the time so let's just say
thank you and let's play this let's get
this party started I also have no idea
what the story of this one is it's gonna
be interesting to see all we know so far
is that you're a little weird look I
almost said yellow looking guy but
that's not it can the game start please
I don't have stuff that's a bell
everyone oh it's not and what do you
think it is then oh [ __ ] oh okay well it
was well that's very creepy o'shea so it
just starts like that we just had a
nightmare a little nightmare thank you
high five
that's a bit low that's what I'm talking
about here we go yeah boy yeah boy just
had a nightmare that's how you wake up
from a nightmare like are we wearing a
raincoat wonder where she got it it's
very cute marcy has a similar one why am
I telling you this I don't know I don't
know all right let me figure out how to
play the game
she sort of grabs it automatically she's
trying to push it I can't do it
this games reminds me a lot of inside I
can was [ __ ] awesome one of my
favorite games last year hey it's the
potato creatures that's not what they
looked like but that's what they're
called now that's the name we're going
with calm down everyone
hopefully this is not as scary as
outlines because I'm getting tired of
scared to scary games man I'm getting
old man what can I say before you judge
me I doubt as as scary to watch as it is
too plain so oh
remember now I have a lighter I don't
remember how you grab stuff it seems
like that's that could be useful okay
I figure out how to grab stuff you can
just hold that mouse button I should be
playing this a control I just couldn't
find one so why did I do this why
exactly
hey food plays greater puzzles everyone
top at him on an entire
there you go she grabbed it now okay my
bad
I'm a [ __ ] idiot as always it
scratched through cool yeah boy
the game doesn't explain anything I love
it yeah not a single [ __ ] thing
it doesn't assume you're a [ __ ] scrub
that doesn't know how to put up it
sounds like I'm peeing doesn't it I like
it I like it a line
the sound of peeing is it's very
soothing to me don't judge I know you
feel the same way okay
what are you doing little girl I feel
like she needs a name Sammy no Sally sue
some southern name [ __ ] alright this is
cool
so far doing a great job this is a Sarah
deaf playthrough everyone first ever
attempt it on YouTube
I swear something move just there can I
pull this out what was that sound hey
baby what's that sound oh god what is
that so oh that's the thing from the
start
hey you're mine now we're going together
adventure with mommy doll and Felix
great times great times were had indeed
oh we're so tiny so cute what is this
place why do we have this do I need this
I [ __ ] it okay let's go
I think we need to go through here Hey
yeah jumping on the band hell yeah
[ __ ] I got an achievement you
can't see it it says highly sprung so is
mob okay let's play the game everyone
press to jump and okay I didn't get the
grabbing part ah conveniently-placed
toilet paper best game toilet paper
you're my new friend toilet paper we're
gonna play we're gonna complete this
entire game with toilet paper I'm never
letting you go toilet paper I love you
your name is Timmy good name I know oh I
just noticed something okay alright
let's let's keep going everyone forgot
that we were playing a horror game look
at the door it's so creepy
all right so gonna have to come over the
struggles of being a tiny person I know
what you're thinking but Pierce
you're relieving Timmy behind never
we're never leaving Timmy behind he's
our friend
he's our lover I said lover that's right
we love each other I wonder if I can
ignite Timmy with flames okay I can't
what it looks like you live another day
Timmy it's your lucky day let's keep
going best friends forever
all right what do we got here Timmy
doesn't look very good does it
looks like a shitty situation all right
get it cuz your toilet paper alright hey
what do we got in the fridge what if I
can come oh yeah boy bye Timmy bye
[Music]
shut up Timmy it's gonna be okay I'll be
back for you sorry Timmy I love you I'll
never forget you Tim it you might you're
my best friend oh [ __ ] it's all Mike
zero deaths zero deaths everyone don't
worry about it it that was a that wasn't
me
hey I woke up from a nightmare don't
interact with a slug
all right well lesson lesson learned
whoop [ __ ] you slug you can you can go
back to your animes or head tags I don't
know this game is so [ __ ] cool so far
huh no no more slacks go [ __ ] the slugs
I mean don't [ __ ] the slugs they say no
hentai Jesus zero deaths by the way
and Sara devs I know I'm breaking the
tension so hard by using this stupid
summer this is so cool I see those slugs
very cool very cool so far loving this
alright could we climb this perhaps
sorna it's dude hey hey we did it yeah
boy oh there we go
eh I'm all through it almost feels like
oh my god the potato people ah [ __ ] oh I
literally fell in [ __ ] where's Timmy
when you need him that's son of a [ __ ]
oh god I hear them but I do oh [ __ ]
they're everywhere oh this is bad
I don't touch me don't touch me peasants
you're disgusting all right
[ __ ] okay push bye
which you could burn them off [ __ ] that
was close I know I keep saying it but
this game is so [ __ ] cool I love how
it plays so far I hope you're enjoying
it as well good jump there Felix a good
job it's almost like you can can't even
tell how you do this for a living
ah potato people there's goddamn
potatoes [ __ ] I'm still alive I'm Sarah
des calm down we're still alive we're
still going strong all right let's take
it a little bit more carefully now boy
or girl or whoever's watching
I ain't discriminating to any gender or
species if you're if you so happen to be
a potato people watching this just know
that I care about you I just saved
myself a polygon article right there
thank you very much all right let's keep
going got old dark a little the Sun I
hope this light doesn't run out that'd
be that'd be great that'd be excellent
where the hell are we some sort of boat
it almost seems like
is that a little hole to look through
the door for like people like me maybe
we used to be friends
I wonder didn't I come from here
no no what's the answer to that okay
that's a bit confusing this is probably
gonna be time so we're gonna have to
hurry so pretty
developers really did a good job go
little girl go [ __ ] you got a run girl I
swear there must be a run button that I
am not worried oh let me try that again
what let's check that let's check the
controls well that doesn't help me does
it keyboard there we go jump
sprint [ __ ] well I should have been
obvious I just I couldn't really tell a
difference sorry about that
pro gamer here pro gamer at flexor xxx
hardcore okay here we got look yes
that's better go go go go go go yeah
that's right that's Hillary Clinton
Hillary Clinton everyone we did it okay
grab it
I extra potato I'm gonna [ __ ] get you
I'm gonna [ __ ] stab you come back
here
[ __ ] I'm too big that's what potato
people soon all right
ready to go my - son of a [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
big area don't like it oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is that what da [ __ ] is that man
Jesus Christ I feel so lucky to be
playing this for you guys this is so fun
no-no-no go in girl what are you doing
girl Ukraine bring some sort of bathroom
now okay I will
Timmy I came back for you
yes hey another one it's his family i
[ __ ] that looks so like you check if
it's safe to me it's safe okay I don't I
don't I don't know I got a funny feeling
about it Timmy I don't know there's so
much toilet oh [ __ ] we're in a toilet
are these toilets look around oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh I see
whoa let's move this story out of the
way let's go sim wet Hey look at that
let's push let's use your family Timmy
the Timmy family trust where the family
always always good to wipe your ass with
hey oh [ __ ] it's time it's time it's
time it's time Timmy I'm not leaving you
behind
go go go [ __ ] Timmy I'm leaving you
sorry Timmy I'll come back for you okay
well you know what hey I see why we have
to do well we're in a kid's playroom oh
that's so cool
hey it's got a little trade and
everything god I'm God I'm sorry I'm
sorry let me put you back oh okay well I
broke it okay there's another
electricity so we probably have to put
the boxes on the sea sighs now just call
in English see so I think that's it
it's one of those weird ones why is it
called a seesaw oh because it's okay
well whatever in Sweden we call it good
good I don't know what do we call it a
sweeter good yeah nice throw buddy you
really nailed it there actually might
not even need the boxes [ __ ] the
perspective it's a bit weird here trying
to walk up buckets it's hard to follow
aah
what's what's the angle of this thing
I'm trying to like hey hey hey for
[ __ ] sake man
yes okay now it's easier we're just
gonna have to run for it I assume what
boy yeah what the [ __ ] oh it doesn't go
up go go go go go go go girl girl you
better go you better go girl
please please please jump jump
no yes okay here we go
attempt number two what who nailed it so
easy easier than your mama's ass
I don't know why I had to go there I'm
so sorry okay we're here now why what
I suppose we could shoot that thing no
why would we do that
hey okay let's think maybe push down
that box was this open before maybe
wasn't open before it okay let's assume
it wasn't open before hey it's a Timmy
family
it's Timmy look who came crawling back
huh okay so I actually don't have time
to interact with Timmy I feel awful but
well hey I can't [ __ ] see dude what
am I doing here okay so I go here well
that was an epic fail okay let's just
see if okay I'm sure this is not
supposed to happen
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry
I sometimes obvious [ __ ] just doesn't
seem to want to you when you're an idiot
all right it's not that easy
all right people don't appreciate [ __ ]
the boxes go go go go [ __ ] box yes
nailed that [ __ ] boy nailed it
what's happening here love the level the
same very very creepy very unusual I
love the sound of me running you hear
that they're rubber ah [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ]
okay
I assume we should not let the AI seus
or else it will end up like the babies
go go go go go
I'm fine
may have gotten a low-lying patient
there and zero deaths everyone Sarah
deaf sorry I'm a [ __ ] idiot I don't
know why I'm so impatient
I should just [ __ ] wait it was
obvious I couldn't have done it it would
have been cool if I didn't do it though
I bet you would have been like hey
that's pretty cool no all right ah [ __ ]
box
I love the sound it's so good no no no
no no no why don't we go in the front
let's go here we go easy easy
know how I [ __ ] that up
all right Lola girl there we go forgot I
had to grab it creepy very creepy let's
put you right there okay there's a thing
hanging there and maybe we need to get
it down I don't know
nothing really here there's a potato
people there maybe drag something I
don't know
now we probably just have to climb okay
yeah yeah silly me
hey it's not always obvious all right
so I'm guessing it looks like we can go
here as well maybe there's something
here let's check it out
okay I feel like I'm not supposed to be
here this way oh [ __ ] what is this what
is happening here what do we got
underneath the bed oh yeah does it leave
footprints yeah that's so cute
hey it's mama baby you coming with me
mama
what what the [ __ ] calm down mama hey
baby we're gonna finish the game
together mama I don't know why I'm
bringing this if you let me marry me yes
I do as i do mama I do so much hey you
never know when you need a mama
all right oh my god no mama mama please
[ __ ] Oh Shay what the [ __ ] is that
oh my god it's looking underneath the
bed and [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] Mon I'm
[ __ ] out here I'm [ __ ] done mate
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] no no no oh [ __ ] I
wanted the first I'm sorry for ending it
here but I want the first episode to be
a little shorter so everyone can get a
chance to get in here this is gonna be a
[ __ ] awesome playthrough I can feel
it I'll make the next one longer for you
guys if you just leave it like and let
me know if you want more I'm gonna play
more either way this is [ __ ] awesome
really enjoying this very cool thank you
guys so much for watching I promise
there will be an outlaw video as well
I'm not gonna reject any other series I
know there's a lot of stuff like Walking
Dead is out as well but it's cool I'm
excited to be playing some more games
thank you guys so much for all their
support as always appreciate you and
I'll see you tomorrow
we're in another video stay awesome bros
[Music]